[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo zusammen da sind wir mit
einer neuen Folge ich bin Stefan
Netzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir
schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid
heute geht es um eine verbrechensart die
noch vergleichsweise neu ist und das
hängt mit dem technischen Fortschritt
zusammen denn unser Fall beginnt mit dem
was man als cybergrooming bezeichnet die
Definition lautet mit dem Begriff
cybergrooming wird die gezielte
Manipulation Minderjähriger sowie junger
volljähriger über das Instrument
Internet bezeichnet das Ziel ist das
Opfer in eine Falle zu locken um
Straftaten wie sexuell motivierte
Übergriffe bis hin zur Vergewaltigung zu
begehen cybergrooming ist so widerlich
und verwerflich dass sich der Bundestag
im Jahr 2020 ausnahmsweise mal sehr
schnell einig war ein Gesetz dagegen zu
beschließen darüber waren dann auch alle
ganz froh wie z.B der cdu-ptiker
Thorsten frei das ist ein großartiger
Erfolg dass wir sehen dass gerade im
Bereich des cybercroomings also des
heranmachens von Erwachsenen an Kinder
zum Ziel der Anbahnung sexueller
Kontakte dass wir dort nicht nur die
eigentliche Straftat zur Straftat machen
sononder dann eben auch den Versuch wenn
am anderen Ende der Leitung am Computer
Polizisten Eltern oder andere Erwachsene
sitzen das ist ein großer Erfolg für den
wir bereits in den
Koalitionsverhandlungen gekämpft haben
und jetzt und heute
Umsetzen der Kern dieses Gesetzes lautet
wie folgt das cybergrooming ist gemäß
Paragraph 176 Absatz 4 Nummer 3 des
Strafgesetzbuches strafbar danach wird
mit freiheitstraf von Monaten bis zu 5
Jahren bestraft wer auf ein Kind mittels
Schriften oder mittels informations oder
Kommunikationstechnologie einwirkt um
das Kind zu sexuellen Handlungen zu
bringen die es an oder vor dem Täter
oder einer dritten Person vornehmen oder
vor dem Täter oder einer dritten Person
an sich vornehmen lassen soll das gilt
seit dem 17 Januar 2020 aber zu einem
ganz üblen Mordfall kam es im Sommer des
übernächsten Jahres leider trotzdem es
ist gut wenn es konsequente Strafgesetze
gibt aber auch sie können uns eben nicht
rund um die Uhr schützen vor den ganz
verwirrten den perversen und den
gewissenlosen und deshalb sorgte im
Sommer
2022 der Mord an een bundesweit für
Entsetzen die 14-Jährige eilen a lebt im
badenwürtembergischen Gottenheim
nordwestlich von Freiburg in einer
Patchwork Familie zu der zehn Kinder
gehören man Geschwister sind schon
ausgezogen haben zum Teil eigene Kinder
und leben in der Umgebung een geht in
dieser Schar als die schüchterne
zurückgezogene rückblickend sagen Eltern
und Freunde die coronazeit sei für een
besonders hart gewesen nur auf Social
Media Apps wie snapchat gibt sie sich
ein bisschen kontaktfreudiger und teilt
auch Fotos von sich über den Chat des
Onlinespiels Fortnite lernt sie in
diesem Jahr auch Jan Heiko P kennen sie
wechseln kurz darauf zu snapchat dabei
geht es recht bald um virtuellen Sex die
beiden tauschen binnen weniger Wochen
über 7000 Nachrichten aus darunter
natbilder und
masturbationsvideos von Anfang an lehnt
een es aber ab sich irgendwie wirklich
zu treffen im realen Leben also und erst
recht will sie auf keinen Fall echten
körperlichen Sex aber ahnt sie dass sie
in Gefahr schwebt weiß sie dass Jan
Heiko fast doppelt so alt ist wie sie
selbst dass er schon von Kindheit an
eine Art tickende Zeitbombe ist Jan
Heiko P beginnt seine kriminelle
Karriere mit 8 Jahren er klaut in
Geschäften Zigaretten CDs Kondome und
Süßigkeiten zusammen mit einem Kumpel
begeht er Brandstiftung in einer
Lagerhalle bei Familie P geht das
Jugendamt ein und aus zeitweise kommt
das Kind in
Pflegefamilien am 25 Mai 2005 das
janheik P 14 Jahre alt verfolgt er mit
seinem Fahrrad auf dem Weg ins
Schwimmbad eine Elfjährige er spricht
das Mädchen an wirkt es von hinten dann
versucht er top und Rock des Kindes
herunterzuziehen die elfjährige kann
entkommen und zeigt den Vorfall an und
so steht Jan Heiko im Dezember 2007
wegen versuchter Vergewaltigung vor
Gericht ein Gutachter bescheinigt ihm
damals eine seelische Abartigkeit P
bleibt 10 Jahre in der geschlossenen
Psychiatrie und obwohl sich
Staatsanwaltschaft und Klinik heftig
dagegen wehren wird er Ende Januar 2017
aus der Psychiatrie entlassen und mit
diesem Menschen tauscht een nun etwas
mehr als 5 Jahre später Nacktbilder und
Videos aus schlimm genug dass sie sich
solche Dateien von einem 29-jährigen
schicken lässt schlimmer aber noch dass
auch so viel von sich preis gibt denn
sie macht sich Jan Heiko gegenüber
erpressbar der Kranke junge Mann will
immer mehr mehr Fotos und Videos erstmal
und wenn een ablehnt droht er damit die
intimen Chats ihrem Vater zu zeigen oder
Familienangehörige durch einen Henker
töten zu lassen
een weiß sich nicht anders zu helfen als
diesem erpresserdruck immer wieder
nachzugeben
wieder Bilder und Filme zu schicken ihre
Mutter wird später sagen een sei in
dieser Zeit noch ernster und
verschlossener geworden seit etwa Mai
habe sie lustlos teilnahmslos und in
sich gekehrt gewirkt sie selbst die
Mutter habe gedacht es liege vielleicht
an Problemen in der Schule oder mit
einem Lehrer wie furchtbar das Kind
steht unter dem Druck eines perversen
und vertraut sich niemandem an ganz
sicher hätte sich alles später
verhindern lassen wenn sie Alarm
geschlagen hätte so aber wähnt sich Jan
heikope auf der sicheren Seite und geht
in die nächste
Eskalationsstufe am Donnerstag dem 21
Juli 2022 fährt Jan heikop mit einem
Ford car von Waldsolms nach Gottenheim
um een endlich persönlich zu treffen für
die Strecke braucht man wenn es keine
Staus gibt etwa dreieinhalb Stunden sie
führt senkrecht über die A5 vom Raum
Frankfurt Richtung Süden man passiert
Darmstadt Mannheim Heidelberg und
Karlsruhe nördlich von Freiburg nimmt
man die Ausfahrt Teningen um sich
westlich Richtung Gottenheim zu halten
Jan Heiko macht die komplette Strecke
ohne Zwischenfälle obwohl er nicht mal
einen Führerschein hat unterwegs Tritter
via snapchat in Kontakt mit ein kündigt
sein Kommen an sie lehnt ein Treffen ab
vehement eroht ebenso vehement wie schon
in der Vergangenheit damit dem Vater
alles zu erzählen irgendwann wird een
klar dass Jan heikop schon in Gottenheim
ist ihre Mutter Patrizia F erinnert
diesen Tag
so Eileen hatte bis 13 Uhr Schule ich
war gegen 14 Uhr von der Arbeit zu Hause
sie hatte mich unterwegs angerufen und
angefangen zu heulen weil die
Pfannkuchen die sie gemacht hatte nicht
durch waren der Teig war schlecht sie
wollte Döner holen gehen ich dachte
wahrscheinlich hat sie Ärger in der
Schule sonst nichts dann waren wir alle
zu Hause ich legte mich kurz hin Alen
war in ihrem Zimmer ich wollte später
mit meinem jüngeren Sohn lwin Schuhe
kaufen gehen es war 36° heiß ich war
schon im Auto wollte Lüften gegen 16:20
Uhr an diesem 21 Juli
2022 sieht F ihre Tochter zum letzten
Mal so erinnert sich die Mutter sie kam
zum Auto als ich gerade mit lwin
losfahren wollte sie trug schwarze
Shorts top weiße Socken und Sneaker een
sagte dass sie noch mal schnell ihrem
Klassenkameraden Benjamin einen Pulli
zurückbringen will einen Hoodie mit
Cordel das war alles etwas ungewöhnlich
weil een ging nie allein weg selbst in
den Nachbarort habe ich sie hingefahren
darum hat mich das
gewundert später an diesem Tag wundert
sich Patrizia F wo ihre Tochter bleibt
sie geht nicht ans Handy Mutter und Sohn
fahren zu Benjamin dem einia den Pulli
bringen wollte er wohnt nur wenige
Häuser weiter keine ein auch nicht bei
einem anderen Benjamin bei dem die
Mutter sicherheitshalber auch noch
vorbeifährt nirgends am Ort ist das
Mädchen zu
finden in Wahrheit ist ein gegen 16:50
Uhr in den fort car zu Jan Heiko
gestiegen die beiden fahren erstmal
nicht weit nämlich in ein Waldstück bei
hugstäten March knapp 10 Autominuten
östlich von
Gottenheim nach etwa einer Stunde geht
es über die Autobahn 5 in Richtung
Norden gegen 0:18 Uhr erreicht der fort
die Autobahnabfahrt Butzbach von hier
aus steuert Jan Heiko das Auto auf einen
getierten Feldweg zwischen langönz ESP
und
kleberg die beiden steigen aus dem
hier kennt der 29jährige sich aus wir
befinden uns nämlich ganz in der Nähe
von Wald Solms seinem Wohnort und hier
besteht Jan heikop zum wiederholten Male
auf Sex mit dem 14-jährigen Mädchen
wiederlehnt sie ab es ist jetzt 0:36 Uhr
gerade ist der Mond aufgegangen man kann
ihn zwischen den Wolkenfeldern sehen er
ist noch recht voll nimmt aber seit ein
paar Tagen ab mit 15
ist es noch recht warm der vorbestrafte
sexuell schwer gestörte janikope
ergreift ein drückt sie mit äußerster
Gewalt gegen einer Holzbank im Wald um
sie zu
vergewaltigen so rekonstruiert es später
Oberstaatsanwalt Thomas
hauburger dabei habe P das Kind mit
beiden Händen so kräftig gewirkt dass es
kurz darauf verstarb nach dem Mord zieht
der Täter vollständig aus und
zerschneidet
messer Reste davon bleiben am Tatort er
legt die Leiche in den Kofferraum seines
fort und fährt etwa 30 km ostwärts zum
Teufelssee die nächtliche Route dürfte
ihn über die Landesstraße 303 Richtung
Butzbach und später auf die A45 geführt
haben am Ufer des Sees kommt der Wagen
zum
Stehen noch am Vorabend also am Tag
ihres Verschwindens meldet Mutter die
14-Jährige als vermisst die
mittelhäische Zeitung schildert die
folgenden Geschehnisse so die Polizei
beginnt mit der Suche Hubschrauber und
Spürhunde sind im Einsatz tagelang
durchkämmen Polizisten Experten und
freiwillige Helfer die Gegend rund um
Gottenheim hunderte Feuerwehrleute
beteiligen sich an der Suche auch einige
Winzer aus der Region helfen mit
vergeblich 29 juli im teufelsse in
echtzell im Wetteraukreis wird die
Leiche eines Mädchens gefunden die
Polizei vermutet dass es die vermisste
ein sein könnte die Leiche liegt schon
seit Tagen im Wasser eine Obduktion wird
angeordnet der See befindet sich in
einem Naturschutzgebiet über 300 km von
eilin Heimat
entfernt das Mörder Jan heikope auf
freiem Fuß war obwohl er seit seinem
jugendprozess als hochgefährlich galt
das gehört zu den unerträglichen
Umständen dieses
dass er aktenkundig ist hilft jetzt
immerhin bei den Ermittlungen und diese
sorgfältigen Ermittlungen führen
schließlich auch zum leichenpfund denn
ein wird nicht zufällig von
Spaziergängern etwa gefunden sondern bei
der gezielten Suche durch die Polizei
das lobt später auch Staatsanwalt
hauburger auf Nachfrage von
bildreporterin danela PF ich möchte an
Stelle noch betonen dieser schnelle
Ermittlungserfolg nurlich
weil wir Zugriff auf Funk
Verbindungsdaten gehabt haben dieser
Fall wä nicht aufklärbar gewesen wenn
wir diese Daten nicht hätten erheben
können und wir haben hier natürlich auch
einen besonderen Einblick in eine Seele
eines Angeklagten bekommen und dessen
Bedürfnisse die erschreckend sind
schockierend sind das habe ich in dieser
Form als Staatsanwalt der schon viele
Jahre Tötungsdelikte bearbeitet so noch
nicht erlebt weil die Bevölkerung
erwartet ja von uns dass wir der schlere
Delikte ermitteln können aufklären
können dann muss man aber uns auch die
richtigen Instrumente an die Hand geben
diese Instrumente sind Datenerhebung
deswegen habe ich auch die Hoffnung dass
auch die Politik diesen wegruf quasi
hört und uns weiterin diese
erwiungsinstrumente lässt oder die sogar
eh noch ausweit am 30 Juli 2022 gibt es
eine Pressekonferenz zu dem Fall es
äußern sich Franz Semling
Polizeipräsident von
Freiburg seit dem Wochenende haben wir
aber die traurige
Gewissheit dass wir einen Todesfall auf
zu zu klären
haben die ermittelnde Staatsanwaltschaft
und die Polizei werden alles daranetzen
um die
Hintergründe des Ermittlungsverfahrens
schnell aber mit der gebotenen Sorgfalt
aufzuklären und semmlingskollege Arno
Englen von der Kripo wir können
mittlerweile
sagen anhand der digitalen Spuren dass
ein in einem
Fahrzeug von Gottenheim
in Richtung Hessen gefahren ist wir
können nicht sagen inwiefern sie dort
freiwillig mitfuhr wie sie ins Fahrzeug
verbracht wurde das ist momentan alles
noch beim jetzigen frühen Stand der
Ermittlungen offen wir würden sehr gerne
zur gegebener Zeit noch mal versuchen
Zeugen zu finden für die Fahrtstrecke
hier kommen wir dann gegebenenfalls
separat noch mal auf sie zu auch die
Medien versuchen jetzt Licht in diesen
dunklen Fall zu bekommen bildreporterin
Lisa Gödert hört sich um in Wald Solms
wo Jan Heiko P ja gewohnt hat vor zwei
Jahren ist Jan P in dieses Haus hier
hinter uns gezogen aus dem Umfeld heißt
es er habe dort gelebt wie ein Student
heißt er hatte eigentlich nur ein
einzelnes Zimmer angemietet das vom Amt
bezahlt wurde da drin hatte er auch kein
Bad keine eigene Toilette sondern B tich
Kommode allerdings hatte er einen
gewissen Vertrauensvorschuss wie es
aussieht hier im Umfeld weil er ist wohl
öfters auch gefragt worden wenn kleine
handwerkliche Arbeiten zu machen waren
er sei handwerklich geschickt gewesen
und habe auch mal ausgeholfen wenn
andere Mieter z.B ihren Schlüssel
vergessen hatten Jan P hatte hier wohl
sehr selten Besuch worüber man sich im
Nachhinein wundert weil eigentlich hätte
er ja regelmäßig von Leuten aus der
Klinik bzw der Behörden aufgesucht
werden sollen wegen der Kontrollen das
ist umso wunderlicher weil regelmäßig
sehr viele gelbe Briefe wohl hier unten
am Briefkasten lagen von Polizei
Staatsanwaltschaft von Ämtern Jan P habe
die aber sogar zerrissen und sich nicht
für den Inhalt
interessiert am 13 Juni 2023 knapp ein
Jahr nach dem gewaltsamen Tod von een
beginnt der Prozess gegen den
mittlerweile 30-jährigen Angeklagten vor
dem gießnerer Landgericht das
Medieninteresse ist groß und
erwartungsgemäß fragt sich niemand ob
Jan heikope der Täter war viel mehr
fragen sich die meisten wie er erneut
zum Täter werden konnte warum lie man
über diesen aktenkundig gefährlichen
Sextäter noch im Januar 22 die
sogenannte Führungsaufsicht also eine
Art enge Bewährung Auslaufen warum wurde
P nicht festgesetzt nachdem man noch in
mindestens zwei anderen Fällen Mädchen
attackiert hatte die Betroffenen waren
zwischen 12 und 17 Jahre alt und
meldeten die Vorfälle auch die Polizei
belässt es bei einer sogenannten gefäh
Ansprache zu einer Vorladung erscheint P
nicht wie die mittelhäische Zeitung
festhält wird PS Fall einem Programm für
mehrfach und Intensivtäter kurz mit
zugeordnet das bedeutet aber keine
permanente Überwachung viel mehr sollen
Straftaten zentral erfasst werden für
spätere
Strafverfahren man kann den Behörden
also keine völlige Untätigkeit vorwerfen
aber keine dieser Maßnahmen konnte
verhindern dass een starb am wenig sie
selbst dabei hätte doch vielleicht ein
Wort gegenüber Eltern oder Freunden
gereicht um den Albtraum zu beenden so
aber bleibt nur die Bestrafung ihres
Mörders und der Schutz der Allgemeinheit
als Ende September 2023 das Urteil fällt
ist den Berichten bundesweite Beachtung
sicher für den m an der 14jährigen ein
aus Gottenheim in der Nähe von Freiburg
muss Jan P lebenslang in Haft das
Landgericht gieen verhängt gegen den
30jährigen Jan P aus Wald Solms im LAN
Dillkreis unter anderem wegen Mordes und
versuchter Vergewaltigung eine
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe zudem
stellten die Richter die besondere
Schwere der Schuld fest und ordneten
eine anschließende Sicherungsverwahrung
unter anderem wegen Mordes und
versuchter Vergewaltigung an damit ist
nahezu ausgeschlossen dass er vorzeitig
nach 15 Jahren in Freiheit kommt ob
Janik irgendwann und sei es in jahrzeh
ein normales Leben führen kann das
dürfte auf jeden Fall ein langer langer
Weg werden denn schon kurz nach dem
skrupellosen kaltblütigen Mord an een
suchte er im vergangenen Jahr in chatz
schon nach dem nächsten Opfer und damit
sind wir am Ende unserer heutigen
Ausgabe angelangt wir danken euch dass
ihr wieder mit dabei wart und freuen uns
immer über Anregungen und Kritik von
euch ihr könnt uns dazu gerne eine Mail
schicken oder uns bei Instagram
schreiben wir freuen uns von euch zu
hören den heutigen Fall haben für Bild
Daniela Pfad und Claudia detch begleitet
das skriipt erstellte Stefan Netzeband
Postproduktion durch schwarz audio
berlin wir hoffen also ihr seid beim
nächsten Fall auch wieder dabei euer
Stefan und euer
Mirco die hat diese Folge von Tat
Deutschland gefallen du bekommst von
True Crime einfach nicht genug dann hör
jetzt in unsere weiteren fol rein hier
warten mehr als 200 spannende Fälle auf
dich wie das Verschwinden von Rebecca
Rusch der Prozess gegen OJ Simpson oder
die Entführung von ursela Hermann wir
hören uns bei Tat Deutschland